i want to give you some predictions um
so i've been thinking about this i said
okay what's apple becoming because i see
apple apple's shifting into like
health in a pretty big way with these
like wearable devices
and so let's just say apple which today
the core benefit is they give you this
ultra personal device you're a little
personal super computer that's going to
help you with life
so i don't think the next apple is a
phone company i think the next apple
the next apple which is gonna be a
trillion dollar company that has
uh that gives you kind of like a
consumer device
i think it's going to be a healthcare
monitor i think it's going to be
something that is
going to be measuring what's going on
inside your body and feeding that data
back to you
and so that's my that's my prediction
the next what the next apple looks like
not a phone company healthcare
monitoring device
next amazon this one's stolen from mark
laurie next amazon so amazon a place to
shop it's not going to be a website
where you uh where you type in a word
and you get 5000 images as a result and
then you've got to sort through them
the next amazon is conversational
shopping in your house
it's just saying what you need and
having something go get it for you
so basically it's just saying hey we
need more pee pads for the dog
and it says you want the same ones as
last time i say yes and then it's boom
it's ordered
right i didn't have to type anything in
didn't have to enter a credit card it's
all on file
and this is a hands-free voice assistant
that helps me shop for things
and when i don't know what it is it
could say i could say hey
um i need a you know the best camera for
my webcam
and it could say something like do you
want the ones that most of the youtubers
use do you want the ones your friends
bought the most
or do you want the one that's the best
value or the highest price and i'm like
uh
what do my friends have sam has this one
would you like to
ask him how it is yes it asks sam and
then sam says it's amazing and then i
buy the thing
right conversational commerce something
like that that's the future that's the
next amazon
next netflix you skipped over 7-eleven
oh i'm gonna do seven eleven two okay
seven eleven the next seven eleven what
is 7-eleven it's a corner store that has
like it's a little local convenience
store this one's easy
this one is um it's a cloud corner store
so you don't need a real location
it's just gonna be 500 square feet
that's within one mile of you
it might be in this back alley place it
doesn't need a good location and it's
going to deliver to you
with small lightweight drones so small
little pass
a small little carrier drone going to
bring you something within 15 minutes of
ordering
no human being involved and the whole
the whole 500 square foot place doesn't
need good real estate
and is going to be automated so that um
you know when i push the button to order
it there's no human being in the place
it just pops out like a vending machine
the drone takes it straight to me and it
lands on a little landing pad that i
have in my front lawn
for uh drone deliveries and as soon as
it's there i go outside i pick it up
the next netflix net next netflix i
think is going to be
one of two things one is it's either in
vr
and it's more like it's a hybrid it
feels like a game so you put the headset
on you enter the world and then you walk
around and you sort of experience a
movie
um so it's either vr or or because i
think i'm not sure about that one
um or it's machine generated movies
which is basically something
personalized to you
so right now a movie is like a really
specific story
that gets filmed edited produced has
actors blah blah
i think you might be able to just sit
down and be like i want something that's
like
breaking bad but with casinos and then
it just generates
it's just machine generates a movie for
you
uh based off of basically it's like a
mashup and you've seen this with
music so google released this thing
called composer or whatever
it's like this ai that basically writes
classical music that sounds like it's
made by bach
and mozart and um and it's basically
just
it's just taking all the stuff that
exists out there it studies it
and then it creates remixes and mashups
of all those things in a way that's
maybe it could be one time it's like i
get this thing and it's like a one-time
movie for me
um that could be kind of crazy remember
that man remember that band girl talk
yeah mashups yeah yeah i used to love
those things man
i still work out to that that's my go-to
for working same i love that too it was
like feed the animal or something like
that
that's yeah that's a great track
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back